cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we got the story from the
post millennial speaker McCarthy
demolishes AP reporter over false report
that house has quote no evidence for
Biden impeachment inquiry this video is
absolutely amazing let's uh maybe I can
pull it up on Twitter make a little
bigger bigger here let's uh let's play
this clip it's a minute and a half long
and it's Kevin McCarthy talking to an AP
reporter I believe it's an AP reporter
what impeachment inquiry is to do is to
get answers to questions are you
concerned about all the stuff that was
just recently learned do you have any
concern
have you asked the White House any
questions yes okay
do you agree that
do you believe the president lied to the
American public when he said he'd never
talked to his son about business
dealings
yes or no it's all right
you can't answer that
do you believe when they said the
president went on conference calls do
you believe that happened
that's what the testimony says do you
believe the president went to Cafe
Milano and had dinner with the with the
clients of Hunter Biden who believes he
got those clients because he was selling
the brand okay do you believe Hunter
Biden when he saw the video of him
driving a Porsche that he got a hundred
and forty three thousand dollars to buy
that Porsche the next day
do you believe that three million
dollars from the Russian oligarch that
was transferred to the Shell companies
that the bidens controlled after the
dinner from Cafe Milano took place
for the testimonies okay then I go back
do you think the president lied that he
but is that an impeachable is lying and
impeachable what you want to know I'm
not saying impeachment all I'm saying is
I would like to know answer these
questions the American public ought to
know and that's what impeachment inquiry
provides so the first thing I'll say is
don't calm down everybody
news organizations do hire
developmentally disabled individuals to
report the news and I know it may sound
funny but it's true
this woman doesn't even know what she's
reporting on slow down there stop
laughing I am being serious
she is not reporting on an impeachment
Kevin McCarthy did not say we are hereby
impeaching Joe Biden he said we're going
to launch an inquiry which is we will
begin to bring together information to
ask ourselves the question should we
impeach
so when he points out all of this
evidence and there's so much more and
she agrees it all exists yes yes said
that yes it said that but that's not
impeachable
Kevin McCarthy is like I'm not saying
impeachment she doesn't even know what
she's reporting on Welcome to the the
modern American Press it's it's sad
because it feels like there are so many
intelligent people and even average
people who just actually watch the
videos and look for the evidence to
understand it better who are trapped
living in a world where you've got a
news media comprised of people who don't
even know what the story is they're
covering and they're friends and their
followers who go and vote so
what I see when I look at that and I'm
like oh there's the two Americas there's
the two Americas where like I hear
everything that he's asking like oh yeah
I heard about that I heard about that oh
I know about that but you talk to my
friends who are on the left and they're
like what are you even talking about
like Joe Biden has never what I don't
know what you mean hunter never did that
hundred doesn't do that did Hunter even
own a gun I mean like we are getting no
like we are getting two different sets
of two different history two different
language you know two different lexicons
two different reports I mean like we
have no way to even communicate because
all of us on the right know all of these
things and nobody on the left knows any
of these things probably because uh
reporters are like no I'd like to uh
give an analogy it is you see your
friends on the left people we know many
you see one day they woke up and they
were on this uh on this ship where a
giant monster with a squid face put a
tadpole in their eye and then the Elder
brain took over their minds I'm making a
Baldur's Gate reference everybody who
has no idea what I'm talking about I
thought you were doing like the biblical
like Speck in your eye log in your
brothers whatever
tadpole yeah the uh the opening story to
Baldur's Gate this is not a spoiler it's
literally the start of the game is uh
the Mind flayer it's a mind that
controls you and it infects your brain
to mind control you and so these people
are quite literal figuratively trapped
in this world where they have this
machine this broadcast tower telling
them what is or is not true and these
people cannot they they do not have the
willpower to ask themselves a shout out
to Brandon strock who is he's the he's
the founder of walk away he tells this
story and there are many people have had
a similar story of how he broke the Mind
Control he says that you know he saw uh
Donald Trump the thing with his arm
where he's making fun of the disabled
reporter
someone told them actually Trump wasn't
making fun of a disabled reporter and
he's like what are you talking about I
watched the video I'll prove you wrong
and when Brandon finally decided to
start investigating it turns out Trump
mocks everyone in the same way and the
the the actual evidence the video that
was made to debunk that claim is
on numerous occasions Trump would insult
someone by going oh look at me I'm so
dumb one time one of the reporters had a
disabled arm and they Twisted the story
to make it seem like Trump was
intentionally mocking his disability
instead of it just being something dumb
Trump does Brandon said he had like this
this harsh moment where he actually felt
pain confusion like wait this can't be
true this can't be real what am I seeing
imagine
just one day you wake up and everything
you believe is wrong dude it hurts it
does it's suicidally painful like I
almost killed myself when I found out
about the liberal economic order fiat
currency the the military industrial
conflict 2006 when I got this washed
over me and like this one thing to learn
about all this stuff when you have no
knowledge and this is just how you're
learning reality it's another thing that
to unlearn 20 years of data what did it
for you like what shook you out I mean
what what was it learning about the way
that Banks can issue infinite amounts of
money or near infinite amounts of money
with Fiat what does Fiat mean it means
faith we have it's not even backed by
gold like I was told I thought our money
was actually at Value it doesn't has no
value what triggered you to like look
deeper war in Iraq 2006 George Bush when
I found out there were no weapons of
mass destruction I'm like what okay now
let's go a little deeper 911 I saw the
buildings fall in free fall I'm like
well they told me that planes knocked
them down why are they falling without
support the entire buildings that uh
it was like thing after thing after
thing and then I'm like why are we in
two wars in the Middle East all of a
sudden when only one of them is is
involved with our attack all of it was
very strange there there are there I got
more there are three great examples from
2000 from the 2006 area-ish that I think
were you know shocking to a lot of
people the first was loose change you
ever see Loose Change no give it to me
so it was a viral documentary Loose
Change 911 second edition it was it was
second one that went super viral and
it's essentially insinuates a conspiracy
or cover-up around what really happened
on 9 11. I am not saying that the
documentary is true that they've
actually issued a bunch of Corrections
there's a lot of speculation I'm not
issuing an opinion on that but for a lot
of people to watch something like that
it changed their perspective on what the
news was telling them and this resulted
in uh you know for me for instance I'm
working at O'Hare Airport and they play
this this video for like you know we're
watching it sounds like you got to watch
this and I'm like what was it like some
guy brings in the break room and I'm
skeptical on everything but it did make
me think like was this really in the
news like these things they're they're
referencing because that's not what I
heard and then I wanted to read more and
more about it to be fair though I had
been on online most of my life so you
know I've been well connected to I I've
always been reading things but for the
people around me that was like all of a
sudden they were getting a different set
of information the next was Zeitgeist
and Zeitgeist moving forward these were
two big documentaries at the time uh
around this period And I think it was
moving forward which explained fiat
currency and fractional Reserve banking
this went viral as well explaining to
people how your money is nothing how
they can just Mass produce it tricking
you into working really really hard for
no reason and then you realize you are
living in a house of cards
that documentary comes out and then just
give it a minute the 2008 crash happens
a lot of people got smacked in the face
and this shattered trust I'm not saying
these documentaries are true and correct
I am not saying that 911 the loose
change video is true and correct I am
saying for a lot of people it shatters
their worldview yeah they might not have
all true data in all those movies but it
was enough to get me inspired to start
researching that stuff well you know if
if those two documentaries did that for
a handful of people because I never
heard of that kova did that
10 to scores of people right because you
know it's it's a little hard to quantify
all the stuff going on with you know
currency manipulation or fabrication or
whatever's going on you know I hear
about the 911 conspiracy I don't know
about that but you tell me that I need
to wear a mask from the entrance of the
restaurant all the way until I sit down
and then I can take my mask and now I'm
okay and that is enough that is so close
and so tangible for enough people to go
all right hold on there man you f you
have you seen the meme where it's uh a
guy standing up and kovid is coming at
his face yeah he's saying that it goes
over his head like it's plastic barriers
between tables so you're fine right
right right I went I went to a
restaurant that it was a so you know in
Frederick the buildings are very small
they're old buildings and the restaurant
was very very small
and I walk in the front door and I'm
standing five feet from the seat and
they're like you got to put a mask on
and I was like I'll just sit down and
First and I'm like
I'm gonna literally say if I sit down I
don't gotta wear the mask right like
they kicked me out oh no or they I
should say they insisted I wear it I
refused and left I'm just saying like if
this if those two documentaries like
deconstructed your institutional Trust
covid
so oh my gosh with so many people like
now even like all the moms in my world
they're like I will never trust my
doctor again and you live in Seattle I
mean that's that's significant this is
what happened to me I I went through
this phase of I will never trust anyone
I do not trust anyone and and this is
like I'm still reeling from that 15
years ago but like a lot of people I
imagine are going through that right now
with what just happened like with
institutions but who do you trust you
have personal relationships you trust
kind of I mean I I it wrecked me this
this this I thought I was the good guy
growing up I'm part of the Empire I feel
like one of the Stormtroopers and I'm
trying to like fix the system but the
Death Star is still heading towards
Alderaan I don't know what to do but
it's not so simple right so let's also
use a different pop culture reference
because it's always Harry Potter or Star
Wars we use Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones was really good until the last
season I do but they had that uh that
Arc where uh what's her name Daenerys
Daenerys Daenerys Targaryen I've never
seen it so I don't know she takes she
takes over that City where they've
enslaved people and and then she strings
up and kills all the slavers or all the
elites and then one guy comes in and
he's like my dad was Elite but was using
his resources to save the slaves and
stop all this and you killed him and
like that's the Nuance of it you can be
in in the Empire fighting for good and
being principled and like no one is
perfect in every single way but you
don't have to feel like a stormtrooper
on the Death Star you know yeah you're
you're you know it's the woke that won't
offer Redemption we will
Redemption it's possible yeah but the
lack of trust that I have now in my
personal life and More in political life
is really what I'm talking about yeah
sure I imagine people are going through
that so like I almost killed myself
legitimately in 2010 but like I didn't
because I had good family the people
that that are struggling right now how
do we help them come to terms with the
cognitive dissonance of like accepting
that some of like because I I'm
genuinely asking thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time